This clip from Jacob Collier is insane.
[Music]
Watching it changed my approach to
speaking and confidence and it might for
you too. Let's take a look.
>> This kind of myth that if you are your
biggest, best, most beautiful self, then
you're going to take up space and
there'll be less space for other people
to be their biggest, most beautiful
self. That's not true. Because the
bigger you are, the more comfortable you
are in yourself, the more space there is
for the people around you to be their
biggest, most beautiful self. No matter
who you are or how you are, being all of
yourself to the people around you, even
the parts that you think are weird or
dark or strange or unacceptable. If I
made music only from the parts of myself
that I thought were kind of pretty, the
music would just suck. You know that you
have to write music by which I mean live
life by digging right into the depths of
who you are and where you come from.
There's no right answers. There's no
right place to come from. You come from
where you come from. And if you pull
from those places and you sing or you
speak or you play, I think it really has
the power to heal a lot of people
starting from you, you know.
>> Cool. Eh,
>> very cool. I love that he says the more
comfortable you are, the more space
there is for everyone else. You are
afraid that if you're too big, you're
going to take up all the space. But what
he's saying is the more comfortable you
are taking up all your space. Your space
is already here. Are you a tiny little
dot inside of it? Because if you're
inside of your little house, you're
freaking out. Then it's scary for other
people. And you feel that. Everybody
knows that the feeling of being with
someone who's deeply uncomfortable in
that moment. And if they're
uncomfortable, then you start feeling
uncomfortable. Then they notice that
you're feeling uncomfortable. then they
start feeling more uncomfortable and it
just hurts everybody.
>> I was thinking like a person who takes
up their body fully versus like a per
the body is there but they are not fully
in all of it. Something about modeling
who you are and in all of its beautiful
and perfect ways makes me feel like that
is the truest form of healing. Maybe
it's okay to be the way that I am as
well. modeling for other people. If you
want to feel comfortable around other
people, model feel by feeling
comfortable and everyone around you will
feel comfortable and it will make you
feel comfortable. And you do that, as
Jacob says, by digging deep into who you
are, not just the surface, but
>> all of the things you're scared will
come out. Let it come out. It's not
You're not going to say the thing that
you're scared of saying.
>> How How do you be that?
>> You have to let your humor come out. And
you might be thinking, "Oh, but I have a
dark humor or a weird humor or a a
childish humor." Let your humor come
out. Let your vulnerabilities come out.
Not the deepest, darkest ones that you
should be keeping only for one or two
people in your life, but most of your
vulnerabilities of, "Oh man, life is
hard right now or this these past few
days have really sucked or I'm really
struggling with this question and I
don't have an answer to it." M those are
kind of negative but vulnerability can
be very positive and exciting too.
>> Exactly. I think of it as my my Tristan
self or yourself around whoever your
best friends are and can you behave that
way or embody the feeling of what it's
like to be around your best friend in
situations where the tendency is to kind
of shrink. Be yourself
>> your biggest best most beautiful self.
>> Expand out into all of the who you can
be. in the past think are weird or dark
or strange or unacceptable.
>> Try things out but very gently, very
lovingly
>> because the bigger you are, the more
comfortable you are in yourself, the
more space there is for the people
around you to be their biggest, most
beautiful self.
[Music]